[Music]
hi and welcome to episode 189 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I'm
mark and I'm here with my colleague John
hey John
how's it going how are you doing today
I'm doing pretty well had a lot of fun
playing video games over the weekend and
I'm having a lot of fun getting ready
for a lot of conferences I'll be
speaking it
oh yeah which conferences are you
speaking at I'll be a pax and also be
speaking at another game summit
somewhere at Google oh yeah like a
little internal game summit where we
talk about some of the plants that we're
working on for gaming as all yep this
exactly it oh that sounds super exciting
it sounds like you're keeping pretty
busy yeah I am hoping to get accepted to
our internal talks that is what I'm
preparing for as well oh it's exciting
can you share a little bit about what
you want to talk about this one's gonna
be a little bit more cross-functional
trying to appeal to teams to start
working on the solutions that will help
improve the gaming space for the
community as opposed to creating the
tools that are necessary to you know
make games easier for developers so this
one's a little bit more for the
community
awesome well I think we have a little
bit of gaming content coming up
speaking of which we do want to get into
our cool things to the week but first
I'm super excited for our episode today
because we'll actually be talking with a
limb from NetApp and Dean from Google
about how file storage kind of exists in
the cloud you know what that means why
it's important and what NetApp is
bringing to Google cloud for people who
want to kind of take their cloud
environments and map up with that
enterprise file storage right and it's a
little bit more of a shift from like
on-prem stuff to it being in the cloud
so they touch on that quite a bit
absolutely we also have our question of
the week which is how do i authenticate
my google kubernetes engine cluster in a
sea icd pipeline so mark you'll talk a
little bit about that have mr. Meighan
yeah don't worry I got this one now
before we get into those why don't we
talk about our cool things of the week
[Applause]
definitely so we're gonna start off with
something that has come out of a project
that one of our podcasts hosts Marc
Mandel has one working on which is a
ganas which is an open source project
that runs equipment Nettie's essentially
a game server Orchestrator and the
product that has now come out that is a
fully managed offering of all ganas is
Google Cloud Game Servers which we're
really excited about I've been hearing
about this since I joined Google and I
knew the roadmap for it and is excited
to really see it come into like being
available for our developer communities
yeah I mean for people who have been
listening to the podcast for a while I'm
sure you've probably heard mark talk
about a gonna swoon or two or three
thousand times but it's so awesome to
see you know mark has been working on
this for quite a while and now it's a
Google cloud product that's going to be
offered so you can check out the link
for more information but it's just is
phenomenal to think about all the work
that he put into it you know now it's
not just mark it's a small group of
people who are just working on building
that out it's just so great to see so
definitely huge congrats to mark for
getting out there and I think a lot of
people are super super interested in it
yeah like you said you can follow the
link and you can sign up for an alpha 4
right now but if you really like you
know get your hands dirty with it
currently you can always just you know
take a look at the ganas open source
project could have gone to star dev
you'll get all the information you need
there including all of the links to the
github repo and any other information to
get you started yeah so you can
implement it yourself or you can use the
service that's coming up ok speaking of
the service that's going up there you
know we're talking a little bit with
NetApp later but we've also got a
partnership coming out with VMware and
VMware you know has a huge stack of
different technology that gets used when
you're kind of in that VMware
environment so it's really cool to see a
partnership between Google cloud and
VMware because now it's gonna be a
little bit easier to take your existing
stacks or some of the the older stacks
that you have around and run them on
Google Cloud so not only do we kind of
get the benefit of the partnership
bringing new technologies to the table
it also makes it a lot easier to take
some of the older technologies and host
them in a more kind of elastic and
scalable way all right I remember using
VMware for the first time at a college
student I will say that it's kind of
interesting to see the shift notes or
Google cloud and I'm really gonna take a
look at that blog post that talks more
about this partnership yeah it's super
cool to see and I think before the end
of the year they'll have on the GCP
marketplace they'll have the VMware
software-defined data center so you can
actually kind of spin up your cloud
version of your VMware environment and
start putting your tools on that and to
close things up for our cool things of
the week it's something for me I've
written a blog post called using GCP
newgate packages in unity so a while
back question of the week and how do we
get our GCP NuGet packages working in
unity and now actually we're in a blog
post that you know details all the steps
and has pictures that move so you can
actually see it happening pictures that
move that's too fancy yeah I don't want
to call it a gift because next you know
I'm gonna get comments like it's called
gifs
oh come on I think that we can first of
all all agree that it's gif and there is
no exception to that rule well there's
all these gifs but more importantly I
think it's the content of a blog post
that matters right that's exactly it and
the cool thing about it is that it is I
guess like say a predecessor for all of
the blog posts that I've been working on
centralizes and using a lot of our
technologies to you know help developers
do really cool things so this is where I
actually started off you know making
sure that I can use these packages
without having to you know do rest calls
or G RPC which may be a little bit
overwhelming for people so I'm just glad
to put this out in the community
hopefully finds it very useful and many
many many blog posts to come by
following this super cool and thanks so
much for sharing it John well I think
we've got plenty of cool things so why
don't we step into our main interview
with a limb and Dean
[Music]
on today's episode we are joined by Dean
Hildebrand and allene Krim I'll let you
guys introduce yourselves oh thanks yeah
my name is Dean Hildebrand I'm a
technical director in the office of the
CTO here at Google cloud hi everyone
thanks for having us on my name is Salim
Karim I'm a product manager at that up
and I cover our cloud volume service for
DCP service okay well to get things
kicked off I'd love to hear a little bit
more about NetApp right this is a name
that I think a lot of people are
stumbled across and it's obviously very
prolific but what exactly would you say
NetApp does so net off has been a
pioneer I would say in the data
management space for probably over 20
years now and really our focus has been
providing enterprise file services to a
variety of different applications and
industries this has been traditional
on-premise environments and so we've had
a very rich history of actually
providing high performance storage for
specific industries like healthcare like
oil and gas like electronic design and
automation to really help those specific
customers develop the tool sets that
they have in their industries to get
their applications to run and this is
where a stability performance and data
management are key tenants of how their
applications work and NetApp has
provided that to them for like I said
the better part of 20 years awesome so
we're gonna continue talking about the
future can you tell us a little bit more
about net up in Google and what that
partnership is gonna look like yeah so
as I mentioned all of these existing
traditional workloads that we've been
running for customers or premise we're
extending that with a huge partnership
with Google that is centered around
delivering those same capabilities
consumable as a set of cloud native
services in GCP so basically first-class
first citizen file service offerings in
GCP using all of the same intellectual
property data management stacks that
customers are used to on prem natively
in GCP and and the partnership really
encompasses several different dimensions
there's the product side which I just
mentioned that's cloud volumes service
and actually the core of the partnership
is solving the core customer problems of
bringing enterprise workloads into GCP
as well as serving cloud native new
workloads
there is the engineering aspect on Co
engineering the service together between
NetApp and GCP we net out bring the data
plain intellectual property and then
Google collaborates us with the as a
service delivery the infrastructure
pieces platform integrations across
Google console metrics billing and
operating at cloud scale there's a go to
market element to the partnership where
we focus on sales and marketing
alignment between both organizations and
dedicated teams for specific accounts
and then finally there's the support
aspect once the service is in GCP how
customers get support actually to Google
fraud takes first client support for the
product and then they escalate the net
up if the need arises so it's a complete
offering across product engineering go
to market support all natively available
in the Google what makes this file
storage necessary I mean when I think of
you know working directly in the cloud
you can have virtual machines you can
add on disks to those for storage and
then anything beyond that need we have
Google Cloud storage right so you've
been able to you know create buckets and
dump files in there that seems to be
pretty comprehensive what is it that
those two aren't covering yeah so I
joined actually exactly two years ago
this week is my like Google anniversary
and Congrats
thanks yeah it's a nice coincidence and
ever since I joined the one for one
thing we heard from enterprises was you
know we want to be able to port our
applications into Google cloud what is
the mechanism you're giving us to do so
and we heard this over and over and over
again and so that was where the real
genesis of the Netta partnership started
but based on that you know what the
customers also said was don't give me
you know a solution where it looks like
two products that have been pushed
together that you know you have a great
platform with all the services and then
there's this thing off to the side but
they wanted to see was native services
or at least look native and they were
supported in a native way and they
provided all of the same you know great
features and availability and everything
else that Google provides in its native
services in any of the partnerships that
we're building and so this is where we
really got the two together and so why
file stores that why were they asking it
for and that's because that's the dawn
storage on premise and so as part of the
cloud when we're talking to enterprises
they're like well this is what we have
we don't have an object store we have
file storage on-prem we have block
storage this is where our databases are
running our ERP systems all of the
critical systems that are running the
enterprise's that's what they're running
on and so over time they might consider
about a modernization and thinking about
how they can build in Google Cloud
storage and one way or the other
but in what they want to do in terms of
leveraging the cloud and really making
the most use of it they just want to
have you know the same high quality
storage that up is offering them on prem
and they want that in google and so in
the meantime these applications they've
all been built for that
you know trillion-dollar on-premise
enterprise mark and that entire trillion
dollar industry is not going to be
rewritten in the next you know few years
and so we really need to build
partnerships with leaders in the space
like met up that can provide all of the
high quality you know durability and
availability of the storage that they
expect on prem and now in the cloud and
just add a few more comments to that
right so really and when you think about
the enterprise space to to Dean's point
this is about an application ecosystem
that supports business processes within
an enterprise and these are workloads
that have typically not been candidates
for cloud right and now we are
essentially enabling customers to make
that transition so that they don't have
to do data plane Dre architecture that
that's point number one point number two
is hey if you got net new cloud user as
you said you could spin up a VM you can
attach some disks to it but you
typically do you put a file system on
those disks right and then you read and
write data to it and now you've got a VM
and a PD that you got to manage right
our point is if you're going to end up
just putting a filesystem on this why
not just give you a file system that you
can attach to your VM fully managed and
you can take it to any other VM without
having to worry about taking snapshots
of that PD and doing a whole bunch of
other things that you would do to
maintain that file system just get the
service it's the clock
if the server and there are some
practical things to it's interesting
when people think about well we have
Google
storage and all the amazing applications
that are using it but then they forget
that when you boot a VM you see a
filesystem and you log into that VM and
you're still using a filesystem and then
the applications that you run such as
you know building your applications and
the whole C ICD pipeline that you might
implement across for your organization
all using a filesystem and so I think we
forget a lot of times that how pervasive
file systems are in our daily lives and
how we really need to make them a
first-class citizen inside of Google
Cloud yeah I mean I think it goes to
show you that all the layers of
abstraction have really made you
completely re-evaluate where you
actually think about what you're trying
to do right and when you have all of
these virtual machines which are
themselves already heavily abstracted
with all these managed services you're
so far away from the file system that
like I think like you said you just kind
of forget about them
so you mentioned lift and shift a couple
of times that is a major component right
because these enterprise companies are
these larger architectures that have
been built based on existing file system
solutions you know they can move to the
cloud using some of these solutions what
about people who aren't lifted in
shifting but actually building new
applications in the cloud is it so
relevant definitely and part of that
reason is that the basic fundamental
about how we build and deliver services
isn't changing even when they are
developing new apps in the cloud so
we've talked to banks for example where
they want to do new products and new
development strictly inside of Google
Cloud when they're doing that process
they're not lifting and shifting
existing applications but they're still
going through the same see ICD pipeline
that they would use somewhere else where
they need file storage
they still need databases and other ways
of managing their data which require low
latency and the types of semantics that
file systems offer them in terms of
managing those systems and so even
though the applications aren't
necessarily literally taken from the
on-prem into the cloud the new ones that
they write there's fundamentally no
reason why they would try to avoid file
storage when especially with that up we
can make it so easy to use that you kind
of again sort of forget it even there
one last thing to add there and I think
there's also a class of applications
that we're seeing specific
in the analytic space where you know
you've got n number of machines trying
to do machine learning or something of
that sort that use libraries that
actually interact with a file share
so another data point that I usually
like to point out is that Google has
done a great job of making github
metadata publicly available on bigquery
so if you just look at that data set and
you look at sort of the two big
programming languages Java and Python as
an example and you look at all of the
new code that's been written over the
last two three years and look at Java
and Python and see how many file calls
those applications are making it's over
half like over half of the source code
files are actually making file i/o calls
and really if you look a little bit more
it's mainly in this machine learning
analytics base where they're using those
libraries and interacting with data
that's on a file system so there you go
file comes back and actually I'll add to
that that tensorflow has two primary
ways of accessing storage through object
storage and again back through on file
and so even though there's many
applications that are lifted shifted as
well one of those is in fact tensorflow
applications and so if people have
developed their machine learning
pipeline on premise in many ways when
they move it down into the cloud the
shift over into object storage becomes a
difficult move and so then they're again
in a situation where if you want to
build a hybrid cloud with a common
storage API across both on-premise and
in the cloud you know again back to pop
storage again you kind of caught me
right off guard I was really about to
ask you a question about on Prem you got
you got me there Dena
ask it again I'll reword it again aleem
you mentioned something that really
caught my eye and maybe this will you
know help us transition a little segue
about net up into cloud though file
storage is pretty much managed cloud but
what I'm curious about is what is
different about that and NetApp then
on-premise and are there really pros and
cons to it and maybe Dean could also
chime in and answer another one of my
questions ahead of time that's a great
question so if you think about you know
the environments being was mentioning
previously on Prem there's a long amount
of time and a large amount of effort
actually stand up a service that you
know an application owner on premise
could use for example file services
specifically what we're doing with cloud
and why this is so different is that
that same application horner that needs
file storage for his app can get that in
the cloud in GCP natively you know in a
matter of seconds minutes let's say you
know for if you really click through the
stuff the time to consume is really
really short right so that's one key
benefit the second is this is now
hitting on the aspect of it being a
fully managed service right so if you
contrast this with the traditional
internet of customers they would
essentially acquire software and systems
that ran storage then put them in a data
center then connect them to a network
then install application servers that
talk to that infrastructure and then
over a number of years have to worry
about expansion of capacity patching
that infrastructure scaling that
infrastructure a refreshing that
infrastructure when its capex life ran
out all of those things essentially go
away from a managed service perspective
right so in the managed service context
a application owner developer whoever is
using this in the cloud just gets that
file endpoint without having to worry
about any of those infrastructure
burdens behind the scenes and not only
that is the entry point to using these
becomes much more tangible
instead of buying you know maybe a
petabyte or two of capacity you can just
essentially use the service to provision
a terabyte or you know even smaller
units of capacity and just get going and
just pay for that little piece that you
mean without having to worry about six
months of installation and lead time
right so really minimizing the time it
takes to get actual access to your
storage and then second abstracting away
all of the infrastructure or low value
pieces that go into running the
infrastructure is what the fully managed
service provides I would just add to
that on premise you ask the
administrator okay what is the SLO of
your you know net box or of your storage
system these are not typical questions
that either are asked nor do they have
the ability to answer there's a lot of
monitoring that is in place that in the
cloud that just isn't there on Prem in
terms of how they understand and how
they think about you know delivering
storage services and I think that's
really you know when we talk about the
benefits of cloud and we talk about how
you know the availability and how we
keep things up and running and keep your
business running in that way the real
shift I think to a managed storage
service comes in the fact of now you are
talking about an SL O's and SL is and
how we maintain the uptime of these
systems and I think that really sort of
changes the conversation about how we
think about storage and how we use
storage my view is that - your basic
point operating infrastructure and
actually providing an application owner
a guarantee is extremely hard if not
impossible to do on premise right we're
basically solving that problem by
bringing the expertise of running a
service between that up and Google
providing the sre resources behind the
scenes so that we can guarantee those
application owners an SLO and SLA for
their particular application and they in
turn can pass that into the business
process that they're supported is that
something that's relevant for a lot of
non enterprise customers I mean you
mentioned earlier some examples of like
banks and other large financial
institutions I'd love to hear more about
you know which enterprise customers this
is relevant for but on top of that what
about non enterprise customers let's
take that for example for what we're
seeing right now and then what what it
means for non enterprise so the adopters
of the service have been in health care
oil and gas electronic design and
automation as I mentioned retail and
they're really running critical business
systems in there and then this is a core
component of what they need to actually
run those systems and approvals to run
those systems in the clock but
ultimately back to the question of do
you need it if you're not an enterprise
this comes down to Opta right this comes
down to availability and durability and
I have you have to meet an application
owner or developer who says that those
things are not important to build on
that you know predictability I think I
would add in terms of how they're using
and deploying cloud right and so what
customers want is a standard set of
guarantees across the entire platform
and so when you look at how we take the
critic
uptime of our Google cloud storage or a
bigquery or any of the other services
file storage fits into that in the exact
same way right it's running critical
applications that all of these
organizations whether they're
enterprises or they're not enterprises
that are using to you know run their
business right I would imagine that your
non enterprise and enterprise customers
probably have faced some type of
challenges there in a way I'm curious to
know exactly what type of challenges
they may have faced and you know what
have you learned along the way like what
kind of changes that Ned actually have
to make to you know suit the needs of
both your enterprise and anonymous
customers we mentioned this notion of a
managed service and it's super easy to
use and you don't have to change too
many things if you're an enterprise from
an application perspective but it isn't
all sunshine and lollipops hey when you
talk about enterprise use cases you're
talking about highly tuned
infrastructure on-premise that is made
for peeking out every second or every
hour of a job completion where is
something like that is a key KPI for the
business you're also talking about I
know high levels of security on
requirements for encryption key
management access controls etc so the
biggest thing I think that we've had to
deal together with between Google and
NetApp especially in the enterprise
space is how do we then alleviate some
of these design concerns and how do we
make the infrastructure optimized in the
cloud not just about the data changes
but how are the compute engine instances
how are the networks how is even GCS
configure to actually ultimately deliver
the same or better output and
performance that that customer is used
to with that workload on-premise and
then the same goes for security across
the board on encryption on key
management on securing the
infrastructure with firewalls etc so
really the challenge is if you look
outside of the storage right and all of
the things that are needed to actually
get together to be plugged in to deliver
that end ecosystem that's where really
the the problem comes in and it's not an
insurmountable problem but that's where
due diligence and getting the right SME
is involved to architect those
environments comes in so one of the
things I would say broadly around the
use of just generally a file storage
inside
Google cloud is I really do believe that
we're bringing you know this old
technology to the next generation of
users and application developers and so
one of the questions that I've seen come
up is well what are the semantics and
why did my file you know get created or
not created and what is this thing
called NFS you know is this a new
protocol I think some people aren't even
aware of you know the 40-year history
that goes back with NFS and that's to me
is awesome
because this is the entire point of what
we're trying to deliver here is to make
NFS space storage and with SMB and then
all of the different access file
protocols that we use will make them
easy to use and consume inside the cloud
and so then you know this next
generation of users that it really isn't
that familiar with the intricacies of
those protocols you know they will get
to know them over time just like they
got to know you know how Google Cloud
Storage works and and how the semantics
works there when you're accessing you
know a buckets from around the world so
I think it really is you know in in many
ways a good problem to have that there
are lots of questions around how this
works and operates in the cloud because
I think that just shows that we've made
it easy enough to use and consume that
the barrier to its adoption is coming
down and it sounds like that's I mean we
were kind of talking about that earlier
but that's a really common scenario for
the cloud right take away a lot of the
not necessarily difficulties but a lot
of the details that you generally don't
care about because they're not relevant
to what you're trying to do and just use
that service for a simple way of
handling oh look I need files it doesn't
matter how they're stored it doesn't add
a header there I want one point to go
connect to it give me the file so with
that being said what is currently
available right now for people who are
using GCP to go use with net app so we
just announced beta availability of our
service and again given all of the
integration work that we've done between
their app and Google this is now
discoverable in the cloud console itself
so if you look at the menu section off
the cloud console if you scroll all the
way to the bottom you will see a icon
that says cloud volumes under partner
solutions you click on that and they see
that'll start your journey to being able
to use file in Google Cloud and as I
said a few minutes and you'll have a
hard volume which is a NFS or SMB
endpoint ready to go and so what's next
right now people can go on there they
can beta it up and try it out what's
upcoming yeah so key thing for us
obviously from a milestone product
milestone perspective is to get to
general availability and we're planning
that in the next few months so we're not
that far away again for those familiar
of you know building services in the
cloud we just have to make the
underlying SLO SLA monitoring and and
all of that solid make that all good and
be able to be you know the sre workflows
and stuff all plugged in once we get to
that state we were good to go from a GA
perspective and then we're past GA you
know we're gonna be adding some key
features that again are key to these
enterprise workloads right for example
if you've got a hot volume in one region
you've got a cloud volume in another
region that's your dr region how do you
efficiently replicate data between the
two so that you can have this for not
just data repurposing but for dr and so
if you think about applications like s
AP and other erp type things they really
need this critical capability so not
only that we've got you know a healthy
roadmap after the GA port so what i'm
really excited about is as we take this
service forward is with the multi cloud
and hybrid cloud capabilities that
Google is delivering with on posts and
other kubernetes platforms it really is
exciting to see how we can plug-in that
up to provide a common data plane across
all of the customers workloads and
really provide again that sort of one
common pane of glass for management
across their on-premise systems in
Google Cloud and even another cloud
environments yeah I think it's great
because it fits in very well with this
need to be able to run things across
environments but it's also really cool
to see that you know Google is
partnering with these companies to offer
managed solutions that like you said are
integrated into the Google environment
right so Google has a history of
building a lot of things but that's also
a lot of things it's a lot to manage and
so it's really cool to see a very
concrete example of how Google can team
up with partners to still integrate
solutions but still kind of have that in
the Google
experience and that was one of the key
things we heard from customers prior to
building the service right is they
wanted to consume the data management
capabilities that we have to offer from
another perspective but they wanted that
service experience and ecosystem
integration to be fully native they
didn't want as Dean pointed out early on
they didn't want sort of a sidecar right
that here's your GCP environment and
then here's your parallel NetApp
environment no they they wanted it all
together not just look and feel but also
as we mentioned support billing
operations capacity management all of
that is you know one pane of glass that
Google and NetApp manage together to
deliver that seamless experience and one
thing I don't think we talked about yet
is how close this partnership is in
terms of in order to really make it a
success I don't think this is something
that we can achieve just on paper and or
in like a weekly meeting at some point
right this is really again about
developers working together about sales
teams working together and really about
just bringing the two companies together
to provide a solution for customers that
they're really looking for and you know
that comes with all of the same you know
team-building and bonding exercises that
you would do even within a single team
you know we've been trying to do across
companies to really again make this seem
like a company is not dealing with two
different companies the really dealing
with one solution and you know a team
that's working together to provide
support for that solution it's awesome
and we're running a little short on time
so right before we let you guys go I'm
wondering is there anything that we may
have missed that you want to cover or
add a little extra Flair on to net up
right before we part ways other than the
open invitation for people to hammer on
that beta right I would say that there's
some key announcements that we're gonna
do over the course of the next quarter
or so so I would ask people to they
tuned about those and the item that
being mentioned around the hybrid cloud
story and being able to integrate with
anthos that is something that we are
very excited and working towards so stay
tuned for those comments
what's next for net app are you going to
be any upcoming events or make any
appearances I would assume that you are
considering that you're going to make in
a couple announcements later on
yes so we'll be obviously at the
summit's as they happen we have a
presence in the Tokyo event that's
happening right now
next Tokyo and then we will be at next
London as well and then next time
Francisco Liam I believe your booth had
a challenge on how fast you can
provision a club volume will we be
seeing that again it was a very popular
contest too I will have to redo it with
some improvements awesome well thanks
everybody and you know thanks for coming
on and tell us a little bit more about
why NetApp is so relevant and some of
them hopefully cool things coming up in
the next few months thank you well they
get to a limb in dean for joining us in
this episode of the podcast it was
really interesting to hear about file
storage and cloud and why it's important
and you know what Knapp is really
bringing for our developers in the
community you know it's fascinating
because it's just not something people
think about or at least a lot of people
don't need to think about like the
specific connectors that you get into it
and I think Dean kind of brought that up
with and straight away from getting too
technical but you know I you don't think
about the actual protocols that you're
connecting to these files with and a lot
of that's been so abstracted away so it
is kind of cool to see like you know
obviously that layer of abstraction
exists because companies like NetApp and
other cloud services make it easy but
there's clearly a lot of work that still
needs to be done to make sure everything
works and that developers can just kind
of ignore it and just move on with what
they need which is I need files give me
the files all right and it's great to
know that NetApp is actually working to
solve this issue yeah so it's super cool
and I think that getting access to that
in the cloud will be hopefully coming up
soon or at least the data will be so
mark let's just jump into our question
of the week
how do I authenticate my google
kubernetes engine cluster in a CI CB
pipeline right so I mean this is a very
common part of hooking up kubernetes to
CI CD because usually when you're doing
this you're using like a headless
environment where you don't necessarily
have the same set of tools or you're
running on a very small box or any
number of things that you don't have
your full environment set up for and you
could spin up the G cloud environment
and authenticate that way so the G cloud
off command which i think is what a lot
of people do from their local
environments but when you're running
this especially in a CSE decays with
your cuckoo Ibanez engine needing to
authenticate every time you push up a
new build you don't really want to have
to configure your environment every time
or have a lot of requirements for it so
there's this great blog post from a met
talking about the easiest solution here
which is to create a cube config file
that includes the authentication and
this is something that you can basically
check in to your repo it's got the
current information for your master in
there or your cluster and then you as a
secret provide the service account so
you create a service account you get the
secret key file you treat that like a
secret because it's well secret and then
in your cube config file you actually
have the authentication against your
cluster that will actually use the
environment variables to pull that
authentication so this gives you a
little bit more flexibility in for
example your CI CD pipeline because now
wherever you're actually running that
build you don't need to install a G
cloud you don't need to go through any
steps you just need to have this very
very short snippet for the cube config
file and then your obviously your secret
config file for the actual
authentication so check out the blog
post I think it's really quick really
simple and you know for anyone who is
figuring out how to build their pipeline
with containers this will probably make
that process just a little quicker that
was really interesting I'm probably
gonna read this because I'm gonna take a
little bit from this and try to help me
when I'm trying to authenticate a lot of
the services that I'm using for the
demos that I'm building for games so I
think there might be a little overlap so
I might take a good look at this yeah
take a look I think it's super cool and
you know it just shows you that there's
a lot of different ways to solve
different problems but you do want to
think about especially as you're
building out a scalable pipeline like
what factors do I not want to have right
like I don't
necessarily depend on having g-cloud all
the time right so very very cool so John
before we wrap up here where are you
gonna be what are you doing what's good
so I will be a pack Stev gonna speaking
with one of our team mates Dingley
regard who is a dpe who also works in
games and that's gonna be our talk on
universal communication is benefits and
games really cool stuff I'm gonna be at
the internal Google game summit whether
I'm speaking or not I will be there it
was fun and a great space to collaborate
with everyone and then I'm gonna take a
little bit of personal travel I'm gonna
go into Montreal gonna be taking my
brother out for a fun trip he's getting
married my twin brother so I'm really
excited for that too because I've never
been in Canada oh that's awesome yeah I
was just up there two months ago not on
the Montreal side but not too far and it
was just gorgeous gorgeous summer so I'm
sure there'll be a lot of fun for you
right so where are you gonna be mark oh
well you know I'm going to Austin this
week or next week and then after that
it's really gonna be coming back to the
Bay Area and sitting you back to the
grindstone getting a few videos out the
door you know I'm super excited because
I think just after this airs the the
next season the stack doctor is gonna
come out and that's with our customer
engineer you're a Grinch Dean that we've
been working on this one for a little
while but he talks more about some
different ways to integrate custom
metrics and monitoring into kubernetes
clusters so I think this will be content
that's really helpful for people
especially when it looks at how do you
kind of take gke
and add-on my custom monitoring and
logging so super excited to hear that
content coming out and glad that all the
work has gone into it and then it'll be
on to the next season it sounds awesome
and congratulations on another season
yeah absolutely thanks so much well we
would like to thank you all for joining
us on this episode of the podcast and
hope to see you all next week
see you mark sounds good see you John
[Music]
okay sorry let me say I was getting the
word synergy and the last thing I ever
want to do is get recorded using the
word synergy so Dean tell me about the
synergy
well I think we need is a lot of B to C
to B synergy between our applications
and our workflows